Transformers Revenge of the Fallen did
not hit her it's not true it's bullshit
I did not hit her
[Music]
welcome back to my Transformers series
guys we have reached the hilarious 'ti
title in his series the second one and
welcome for the very first time to my
new hilarious 'ti set I had such a great
time building this and I was really
surprised how cheap it actually was
turns out nobody wants really crappy
movies or really crappy movie
memorabilia it's all pretty much being
given away especially that Turrell
Battlefield Earth action figure I don't
even know that should existed so I
looked it up and now I own it and I'm
glad that I do so revenge of the Fallen
was of course highly anticipated by tons
of people and I remember going to this
with my friends and when it ended a
friend of mine he had brought his
fiancee and she turned to me and she was
like what wasn't that awesome didn't you
love that and I was like mm not really
not so much and she went what how could
you not like that I haven't talked to
her in a while in my review of the first
Transformers I mentioned that it's kind
of hard to be critical about the
Transformers because you know it's just
made for fun they're they're toys that
turn into things and you can buy the
toys and kids like it and it's enjoyable
and entertaining it's tough to really
look at these movies and be like her
except with this movie because this
movie's ass and I don't like it at all
it's a lot easier when they completely
miss the point of what fans want and
they go the exact opposite direction in
this film Michael Bay and his writers
thought well people don't care too much
about the Transformers they just want to
see a lot of Shia LaBeouf's parents we
have them accompanying Sam to his first
day of college and the mom eats a
marijuana brownie I mean what a great
scene we also are greeted with tons of
dog sex I mean can you imagine actually
being on set that day like instructing
the cinematographer okay now slowly
dolly in on the butt fucking dogs
this entire film is actually filled with
really annoying characters his roommate
from college Leo accompanies them on
their entire adventure and he just
screams the entire time like
he's addicted to ecstasy and of course
there's mudflap and skids the two robots
that were heavily accused of racism oh
my god wait a second I don't care
anymore
what were my problems with this movie
again I forgot about everything I love
this movie this movie's perfect so let's
talk about the plot of Revenge of the
Fallen the plot I called it a plot that
was cute of me to call it a plot it's
really just a series of events that were
written possibly because this movie was
made really fast because there was a
Directors Guild strike and a Screen
Actors Guild strike and there were all
these possible strikes looming over this
movie and they had to like really
quickly come up with a plot and so what
do we get well a sliver of the cube from
the first movie was stuck - Sam's shirt
and he touches it and he goes insane and
he starts seeing these words in his head
and it leads him eventually down this
path to the ancient fallen and it gives
me some of my favorite parts in this
entire movie because he just goes nuts
when he's in the middle of college and
takes a book and he's like what it what
I dislike the most about this plot is
that it all starts because he touches
the sliver of the cube now this guy was
running through the streets holding the
entire thing for the end of the first
Transformers movie like it was a big
thing he had to run up to the top of the
building and then he eventually put the
Allspark cube into Megatron and
everything he's touching it what is
touching one little part of it after
doing anything he grabbed the whole
theme the first time around it's so lazy
and just like the first one we have a
whole bunch of military subplots we
constantly cut back to the military and
some guy will say some big scene ending
line that's meant to strongly transition
you into the next scene and no confirmed
dsrvs on
then people we've got a problem and
revenge of the Fallen has one of the
dumbest movie cliches ever it's where
you don't take the time to explain
anything someone's walking really fast
talking really fast and they got a paper
so no need for explanation we take our
showers I'll see your chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff and have a raise
you the President of the United States
hey you can't be here hey shut up I got
a paper and I'm walking fast you got
nothing on me bitch and if Michael Bay
constantly hovering the camera around
the bodies of many beautiful women
wasn't creepy enough here we have Rainn
Wilson as the creepiest non serial
killer character I've ever seen maybe he
is a serial killer uh-huh that would
explain a lot he's a professor in this
class flirting with every single hot
girl in his front row now look it made
sense in Raiders of the Lost Ark when
all the girls came to Harrison Ford's
class because Harrison Ford is extremely
handsome and good-looking in that film
he was oblivious to it he didn't even
notice it in this film we have this guy
and every like porn star looking girl is
in this front row wanting to fuck him
and he's totally into it well what do we
know about the stars and once again
revenge of the Fallen has another
reference to one of Michael Bay's other
films
Shia LaBeouf literally goes right up to
a poster of bad boys - and starts
drawing on it isn't that nice
there's also a Cloverfield poster
interestingly the Cloverfield trailer
premiered with the first transformers I
remember being there like what is this
movie this is a Godzilla movie what is
this about
so that's kind of a cool little easter
egg but of course he had to slap a bad
boys 2 poster right next to it you can
even see a Michael Bay film like the
text right above it easily the best
senior revenge of the Fallen is the
forest battle it's really entertaining
it's a big epic action scene it's about
the best this movie has to offer in
regards to fun but don't worry the fun
is quickly replaced with the fact that
John Totoro is in this movie again now I
love
- Turo as an actor but in this film his
character I just don't need him in this
movie I don't I really don't need John
Turturro in this movie but he's in the
movie and trust me I really did not need
to see this that's another thing that
I'm not gonna be able to unsee that this
movie showed me we got dog sex
we got john tudor rose ass and this
robot humping Megan Fox's leg I just
want to know who told the people who
made this movie that all of us
Transformers fans don't really care too
much about transformers and what we
really want is dog sex marijuana
brownies humping a leg and John to Toros
ass whoever said that they they
shouldn't have said that
so in real life Shia LaBeouf had a hand
injury during the making of this movie
and it's really clear that they just had
to write it into the film because they
magically get zapped to Egypt and they
learn a whole bunch of exposition about
the fallen and all that but I guess he
got injured when he got zapped because
suddenly he has a very legit clearly
medically applied hand brace I mean so
lazy
just I constantly find myself just in
thought during this review just
reflecting and pretty soon they're
babbling about Orion's belt and that the
three stars in Orion's belt point to
something and that's the answer I guess
it really just feels like every day they
came to set and somebody held up new
pages and said we wrote this it has
nothing to do with this movie but we
wrote it and we're all gonna perform it
on camera today and eventually they just
kind of strung those moments together
and somehow because Michael Bay is good
at assembling competently well-made
productions everyone was like fine with
it one of the coolest sequences in this
movie is with a Devastator that's some
really really cool shit but of course
since we didn't have enough
jokes already the Devastator apparently
has some balls I just don't I don't know
what they were thinking I really don't I
will say this Megan Fox is better in
this film than she was in the first you
can tell that she probably took some of
that criticism and took some acting
courses or something I don't she is
better in this movie than she was in the
first one
bumblebee school when he when he rips
the thing spine out I'm constantly
looking for things to praise whenever I
talk so much shit about a movie because
it's not like everything in this movie
is bad there are good things in this
movie obviously the special effects in
the production and everything it's it's
great you can look at it it's it's nice
to look at and that's about it so of
course we get the big humongous finale
action sequences where the pyramids are
being blown up and John Tudor rose on
top of a pyramid and he sees the
Devastator is gonna seriously start to
wreak some havoc some world ending Sun
exploding havoc and he just grabs a
radio and calls a battleship out on the
ocean and goes you need to fire missiles
at the pyramid right now otherwise a
whole bunch of people on the earth are
gonna die and the guy in the battleship
is like okay fire a missile it's a
pyramid what this guy on his fucking
radio got them to shoot missiles at the
pyramids just fuck off just just and
already gratefully the movie ends pretty
soon oh man this movie of shit oh yeah
Sam Witwicky has a death vision he goes
unconscious he has the death of vision
and like voices bring him back to life
it's this movie man I don't know what to
say oh my god well guys stay tuned for
my review of Transformers Dark of the
Moon that's gonna be fun thank you so
much as always for watching I hope you
guys have a good one if you liked this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]